après des mois d'entraînement houston au
texas où il vit avec sa famille david
saint-jacques change de décor plusieurs
fois par année
il vient s'entraîner en russie là où se
trouvent les répliques de la partie
russe de la station spatiale et du
soyouz le véhicule à bord duquel il va
voyager dans quelques mois
cinquante deux vies parallèles des fois
j'ai l'impression que quand j'arrive à
l'aéroport à chaque de moi pourquoi je
suis ici j'ai eu à l'aéroport à houston
c'est comme si l'entraîneur je passais
dans le ciel de miroirs dans alice au
pays des merveilles et qui je demande à
mon entrevue david devait de russie au
milieu d'une grande forêt à quelques 40
km de moscou se trouve la cité des
étoiles
ce centre de formation des cosmonautes
fêtera ses 50 ans aujourd'hui et il
porte le nom de iouri gagarine le
premier homme dans l'espace
bruce soviétique c'est d'ailleurs
l'avion qu'il avait l'habitude de
piloter que vous voyez derrière moi et
david saint-jacques site ici qu'il
s'entraîne quand il vient en russie dans
un décor qui n'a presque pas changé
depuis cinq décennies
depuis les glorieuses années du
programme spatial soviétique
c'est pratiquement tout se passe en
russe une langue aujourd'hui david
maîtrise bien nous l'avons vérifié que
les nationaux ici on se pratique à voler
sur le seuil ou alors tous doivent
comprendre le russe dit il
les communications radios sont en russe
et toutes nos conversations avec les
autres membres de l'équipe
aussi les conditions pour voir se
comprendre à demi mot c'est d'autant
plus important qu'on reproduit ici des
situations peu banal aujourd'hui une
fuite d'ammoniac qui oblige l'équipage a
quitté précipitamment la station il ya
quelques urgence à bord qui sont
tellement catastrophique que vraiment la
terre ne peut pas nous aider et
d'équipage doit
et cela prend des décisions un feu à
bord une dépressurisation et sa consoeur
des toxines revêtir un scaphandre
rapidement tout en portant un masque à
gaz s'engouffrer sans attendre dans le
ça use à bord duquel david sera copilote
le tout supervisé par les entraîneurs
russes pour l'équipe composé d'un russe
d'une américaine et d'un canadien
la politique est toujours un peu en 39
ans on dit david saint jacques
surtout quand la situation mondiale
étendue entre nous le vainqueur de
l'équipage non on est notre notre but
justement c'est de deux contribué au
resserrement de contribuer à cet effort
de l'unification son jeu de l'humanité
parce que quand on a la perspective de
la terre vue de loin comme ça on peut
c'est difficile de ne pas espérer qu'on
puisse mieux vivre mieux travailler
ensemble et on essaie d'en faire la
démonstration aux questions en fin de
journée une banale balade en ski de fond
fait aussi partie d'un entraînement
rigoureux à peu près dans l'espace tout
se sait pas très bon pour le corps être
en orbite
donc il faut commencer au plus haut
niveau possible et puis pour pouvoir
revenir en bonne forme
[Musique]
son prochain séjour de ce côté de
l'atlantique david saint-jacques le
passera dans un tout autre décor à
baïkonour kazakhstan où il fera partie
de l'équipe de relève avant son
véritable départ prévu en novembre
prochain
ici alexandre à chaska radio-canada
moscou